il a dit bonjour bonjour ci sera
évidemment ces sanctions pas de
distanciation vis-à-vis du gaz et du
pétrole russes en tout cas pour le
moment rappelez-nous peut-être les
chiffres illustrant notre dépendance
envers les hydrocarbures but russe ça
expliquera beaucoup de choses mais
l'agglo chiffres très simplement 40% du
gaz consommé en europe et 27 % du
pétrole consommé en europe est d'origine
russe donc la dépendance est très claire
alors c'est pas pareil dans l'ensemble
des pays nous par exemple en france 7
17% notre dépendance par rapport au gaz
russe mais en revanche dans un certain
nombre de pays d'europe de l'est ce ça
monte jusqu'à 100 % et en allemagne
c'est 50% si ces disparités qui fait
qu'il ya des négociations en ce moment
et on le verra demain sans doute à la
réunion des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement à versailles ils n'ont que
l'europe décide de fermer le fameux ce
robinet à quelle conséquence il faudrait
s'attendre d'abord rupture d
approvisionnement très clair peut-être
pas là dans les semaines qui suivent
mais sûrement très clairement sur
l'hiver prochain 22 23 ensuite
évidemment là tout de suite augmentation
des prix du gaz et du pétrole est
désagréable mais a grimpé à des records
pas vu depuis des décennies on parlera
aussi de rationnement on serait
rationner en europe au moins des
entreprises rationnées peut-être
également des particulière nous annonce
caution diminue d'un petit degré notre
chauffage on nous demande à nay à rester
en france déjà on est dans la
perspective de du premier choc pétrolier
ou en dodon nous demande de faire un
certain nombre de sacrifices ensuite
augmentation évidemment pour l'industrie
les services et puis l'inflation des
prix les européens évoqué hier en tout
cas se pencher sur la question des
alternatives aux hydrocarbures russes il
y en a bah oui mais elles sont légères
comment se passer de 155 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz qui sont fournis
dans le cd on peut demander à l'algérie
à la norvège au qatar aux états unis
faire des progrès mais on n'arrivera pas
au même nos jours peut signer également
demandé aux renouvelables de pousser
leur progression on peut faire des
économies d'énergie mais quoi on va
gagner quelques milliards de mètres
cubes seulement mais absolument pas les
155 bon la commission nous promet qu'on
va pouvoir je sais pas comment
économiser deux tiers de nos relations
avec la russie d'ici 2023 à voir bon si
je vous entends bien si je vous suis
bien à lille c'est un peu la fausse
bonne idée de fermer ce robinet mutilé
l'objectif les sanctions l'objectif des
sanctions et politique c'était de
ramener la russie à la table des
négociations pour retrouver la paix
l'objectif des sanctions ce n'est pas de
déclarer la guerre économique à la
russie parce qu'il faut imaginer le coup
d'après et le coup d'après faut
l'espérer c'est quand même de retrouver
un certain nombre de relations amiable
avec nos amis russes voilà justement